>> Today, I'd like to introduce you to Joshua
Green who has co-authored a book with Jean
Burgess titled "YouTube: Online Video and
Participatory Culture."
Josh is a postdoctoral research fellow in
the Comparative Media Studies Program at MIT.
And he is the research manager of the Convergence
Culture Consortium which is a research project
at MIT that provides strategic insight into
the contemporary media landscape for a range
of industry partners.
Joshua's work focuses on new forms of television
and online video and participatory culture.
And this book represents the first large-scale
survey of YouTube's content, structure and
uses.
So, without further ado, I'd like to introduce
Dr. Josh Green.
>> GREEN: Thanks.
Good day.
So, thanks for coming.
My name is Joshua Green.
I'm going to talk about YouTube and I suppose,
you know, sort of speak up-–talk about the
book that a colleague and I completed quite
recently.
This is a collaboration between my research
group at MIT and Jean Burgess who is a very
old friend of mine who works at QUT in Brisbane.
And this is an attempt to sort of grapple
with how we understand what YouTube is.
We both work in the field of media studies
and cultural studies.
And what we are intrigued about and what we
were trying to understand with this project
is: How do we contextualize this new thing--this
sort of blip on the landscape that seems significant?
How do we make sense of YouTube when it itself
is an incredibly complex object.
How do we come to terms of what it's being
used for?
And how do we locate it within the kind of
discourses around the evolution of participation
online, the future of media and all of the
other things that YouTube is wrapped up with.
And so what we did with this book and what
I'll talk about today somewhat briefly is--you
know, we sort of--we asked these very--three
very simple questions: What is YouTube?
How do we make sense of it?
And what ultimately are the implications of
YouTube?
And, of course, these things end up being
kind of more complex.
So the answers to these questions are more
complex and the questions not as simple as
we thought they might be.
What we wanted to do with this project was
to push together two methodologies.
We come from a media and culture studies background
which traditionally is small-scale, deep investigation,
and rich interpretation of text.
When you're dealing with something like YouTube,
there is a tendency to explore YouTube in
order to prove whatever it is that you might
be interested in.
So, what we wanted to do was rather than look
for particular types of content or particular
types of uses on YouTube and then extrapolate
out from there and say therefore YouTube is
for political engagement or YouTube is for
cat videos, what we wanted to do was to instead
try and get a sense of the scope of YouTube,
and then try and understand how the different
bits of it work together and then sort of
mix the range of content across it.
And this requires a methodological innovation
that I'll talk about later.
But sort of at the core of these two activities,
one was an attempt to locate YouTube within
the competing discourses that come to define
it--so, within the popular press, within the
sort of the political experience, within the
debate around activism, around media culture,
around advertising, around new modes of participation.
And the other thing we did was draw together
a sample of north of 4,000 videos that were
defined as most popular, and that's where
we get to some of the politics of the work
that I'll talk about in a minute.
Looking at YouTube, YouTube presents us with
an opportunity to confront some of participatory
culture's most pressing problems.
You know, looking at YouTube, we can engage
with questions around the unevenness of participation
and voice in this kind of democratized new
age.
We can look at the apparent tensions that
emerge between commercial interests and public
good.
YouTube is simultaneously, you know, a big
commercial system and also it's a repository
for our popular culture.
You know, we can look at the contestation
of ethics and social norms that occurs as
belief systems clash together, you know, because
YouTube supports that sort of stuff, the way
the interests and culture differences collide
on a space that tries to support all of these
diverse uses.
In later chapters, we focused on some of the
norms, of the most important new debates around
the creative industries, about new media,
of the new economy, issues about user-led
innovation, amateur production, questions
of labor, and the apparent tensions between
global connectedness and commercial monopolies.
And so what I want to do is start by addressing--sort
of locating YouTube and starting with the
very simple question which is where we started
and that is: What is YouTube?
And this becomes an increasingly complex question
because YouTube is not a singular thing.
My background is in studying television.
This is a quote from a guy working in the
UK called Stephen Heath.
And in 1990, he was writing a chapter in a
book where he tried to define what television
is, and he goes through a range of different
ways to try and understand what television
is before coming up with the ultimate conclusion
that television is an unstable object.
Depending upon how you look at it, television
changes its constitution.
You know, and so what makes television an
unstable object are the speed of its changes--if
we think about the broadcast era, every day,
there was a new version of television reinvented
for us.
It has this interminable flow of content.
It's very difficult to stop television and
look at it.
Because if you stopped at any one minute,
you're only looking at the television from
that instance, and this becomes increasingly
more complex when we look at television across
national systems.
And, finally, Heath argues it's the kind of
quantitative everydayness.
So the fact that television is this really
simple, domestic thing that is in our lounge
rooms that we don't think about a lot that
makes it an unstable object--means it's subject
to all these different definitions.
You know, in the great respect, I think this
comes to define YouTube as well.
You know, we can think of YouTube as a thing
but a fundamentally unstable thing.
And so we know a few things about it.
You know, it is massive.
You know, these are the recent figures: You
know, it's got a 40% market share and, of
course, YouTube is rolled into Google sites.
When we look at comScore Matrix, there is
a 40% market share of video streams in the
US.
What's really significant is the next largest
player, you know, regularly commands only
a 3.7% market share.
When we look at in terms of overall streams
served--YouTube is quite clearly on the Google
sites--quite clearly the thing that looks
like Pac-man.
You know, and even if--and there are all of
these questions at the moment around: the
veracity and the reliability of video metrics.
But, you know, even if hulu is making--gaining
ground in terms of minutes served, YouTube
and the Google sites simply outstrip everyone
in terms of the shear amount of content delivered.
You know, the same time, YouTube is wrapped
up in these discourses around what it means
to participate in participatory culture.
When Time decided that "You" were the person
of the year, they chose to represent "You"
as YouTube.
You know, I mean, it's--ultimately, they're
not saying YouTube is the person of the year.
I don't want to beat up on Time here.
You know, but the image, you know, and the
kind of iconic representation of "You" that
Time gives us is the YouTube kind.
You know, the prospect of broadcasting yourself
comes to define or is an easy shorthand for
what it means to participate in participatory
culture.
And this is particularly interesting when
just as of last week or the week before, Time
names YouTube as one of the ten greatest technological
failures.
And so on the one hand, you know, it's representative
or iconic of the potential of participatory
culture.
On the other hand, it can be, you know, seen
as a failure.
YouTube is a cultural archive.
You know, it's possible to run out of nostalgic
moments to watch on YouTube before you have
even scraped the surface.
So these are--and this is actually a work
of my coauthor--these are three of her favorite
moments.
You know, and these are kind of iconic moments
in the history of Australia or rather in her
recollection of what it means to be Australian.
At the same time, it is this platform for
incredibly diverse range of activities whether
it's something like showing off--so just how
well and how kick-ass are your skills on the
Guitar Hero, whether it's just instructional
video--the one up on the left is Depression
era cooking; so it's someone interviewing
their grandmother who is talking about what
it was like to grow up in the Depression which
is, of course, somewhat salient in the kind
of economic climate.
You know, it supports these debates: the atheist
versus creationist debate--or the evolution
versus creationist debate is something that
rages long and long on YouTube.
And it's also this space where you can run
into beautiful things.
And as Jean likes to say--you know, the last
video on the bottom left-hand side is a love
song about Mario from Mario Brothers, you
know, and his pining love for Princess Peach;
and it's one of the most beautiful things
you will ever hear.
It's also this site for innovation and this
is a recent project that is one of my favorite
uses of YouTube.
Okay.
Clips of music or the music instruments in
and of itself--so by going and sampling and
the grabbing and editing together, all of
these little public performances, you can
use YouTube and play it as if equal with some
other instruments.
It is, you know, it is a mean-factory.
You know, YouTube both helped us to understand,
you know, the viral video and likewise has
served a substantial number of those; many
of which, as in the case of "keyboard cat"
and [INDISTINCT], you know, all four of them,
get reversioned and rearticulated.
As YouTube becomes--is a generative space,
and people come to it in order to reuse the
materials there in order to produce something
else.
At the same time, YouTube is a platform for
the distribution of professional content.
And if we look at the channels which are most
viewed, you know, we see along the top row
particularly a number of large--what we refer
throughout the book as traditional media producers.
And we'll talk a little bit later about the
significance of music on YouTube.
And this is something that the company itself
is pursuing, you know, particularly within
the US; and there is a range of politics around
that.
You know, as the company looks, you know,
for that efficient monetizable model, you
know, it's increasingly presenting itself
as a space that can serve in-depth ways--professional
media produces.
YouTube is wrapped up in discourses of concern.
You know, the girl fight videos struck a particular
court in the UK particularly where YouTube
was implicated in the creation of cyberbullying,
in the destruction of classroom behavior.
YouTube is also implicated in the death of
TV advertising.
When WIRED wrote about the lonelygirl15 experience,
what I find so interesting about this cover
is that right up the top, you know, right
next to YouTube, they talked about the potential
or they implicated the potential, death of
TV advertising, even though what we saw was
an experiment in participatory culture and
online video by a bunch of film makers.
But thinking about these things helps us think
about how we are reinventing, you know, the
broadcast media space.
And the recent PRS debate around licensing
fees in the UK, you know, points to the way
that perhaps YouTube is being implicated in
the future of music as well.
And so here we have this thing, and these
are only some of the ways that we can think
about it.
I think what's significant when we're trying
to work out what YouTube is is that we realize
that YouTube itself was undetermined.
When it was invented in 2005, it was launched
with incredibly humble origins.
You know, it was a start-up by three former
PayPal employees, you know, who are looking
for an easy and free way to upload and publish
videos to the Web which, you know, at that
time, was something that haven't quite been
cracked yet.
YouTube was one of a number of sites, many
of which looked pretty much the same.
And there's an interesting TechCrunch article
from 2005 that compares at the time the leading
online video sites under the mantle, under
the header--sorry--which will be the Flickr
for video.
You know, so what it was that YouTube was
trying to be was not quite determined.
And I think this is apparent in the fact that--I
mean, this is a--at the back there is a screenshot
from the Wayback Machine's version of the
YouTube site from 2005.
Perhaps it was about online dating.
Perhaps that was the way, you know, that the
site was going to make its money.
It was about social networking.
So sharing your videos, you know, affected
or achieved a technological need.
You could pass this content on to somebody
else.
But how are we going to make it payroll?
Maybe people will come to it so they can meet
other people.
And if we look at the very, very first video
that was ever uploaded to YouTube, I think
we get a sense of both the uncertainness about
the medium itself when it was launched, but
also the inherent ordinariness with which
YouTube launched.
>> All right.
So here we are with one of the elephants.
A cool thing about these guys is that they
have really, really, really long tusks; and
that's cool.
And that's pretty much all there is to say.
>> GREEN: So that's "Me at the zoo" which
is the first video.
And I think it capitalizes--crystallizes,
draws together many of the ways many things
we think about that is wonderful about YouTube.
So the argument that we pursue in the book
is that what YouTube has become now is the
result of a process that puts and others refer
to as consumer co-creation, that ultimately
YouTube is the thing that is it not because
of some kind of deft design, but because it
was a platform that was produced by the activities
and the implications of a large range of ultimately
consumers, participants within the space.
And so the site's value, what it has turned
out to before, has been co-created by YouTube,
Inc. which is now owned by Google.
And the users who upload their content to
the Web site--the audiences who engage around
that content and this group of contributors
is incredibly diverse.
And we have large media producers and rights
signers, you know, we have small to medium
enterprises who are looking for cheap distribution
or alternatives to broadcast channels.
We got cultural institutions.
We've got artists.
We've got activists.
We've got media literate fans.
We've got nonprofessional and amateur media
producers.
You know, each of these participants, along
with YouTube Inc., approach YouTube with their
own purposes and their own aims; and, collectively
and collaboratively, or rather, collectively,
they shape YouTube as a dynamic culture system
however imperfectly realized it may serve
any of these groups.
And many of these groups are substantially
disappointed with YouTube along the way.
Sometimes, it's great.
Sometimes, it fails them outright.
You know, sometimes, they can monetize their
content; sometimes, they can't.
Sometimes, they can engage with other fans;
sometimes, they can't.
Sometimes, they get stuff pulled down and
they don't understand why and, sometimes,
they don't.
You know, sometimes, it is this wonderful
things for all of these users; and, sometimes,
it comes up short.
And what I think is so interesting about this
is that what YouTube has become has been a
result of the participation of all of these
users even if they all don't realize that
they're all participating in the space at
the same time.
I think they all treat it as if it's a space
designed for them or a space that has the
potential for them to achieve their goals.
But, at the same time, it's supporting such
a diverse range of users that what it can
be can only be determined by the kind of pulling
and stretching that comes from the relationship
of all these groups which places a problem
then if we're trying to make sense of it.
If we're trying to appreciate its size, its
scale, its shape, what it could be used for,
what its potentials might be, what its ultimate
value might be, you know, this diverse range
of uses and users is kind of a speed bump.
And so we perhaps foolishly thought we could
solve this problem or perhaps we could at
least come about it; and we did so soon after
we started this project, soon after Viacom
launched its legal action against YouTube.
Actually, this was incredibly motivating for
us because Viacom's claim was--and you'll
have to excuse me if I don't get the nuance
of it right--but Viacom's claim was, you know,
that the most popular content that drives
the value of this site is ultimately produced
by large content producers.
It's only to the realm of the claim I think
speaks to "where does the value come from"
and "what is most valuable."
And these claims struck us as strange because
it seems to approach YouTube in a particular
way.
And so, to a certain extent, we wanted to
test that.
But, really, what we were looking to try and
do was to understand how we can understand
popularity on the site, because that seems
to be at the heart of much legal action against
YouTube.
And there a lot of interesting ways to try
and understand popularity and there's a lot
of very good work--work like this that maps
over time, say, user-generated videos and
their life cycle, the number of views, how
long between when they're uploaded, when did
they peak, when did they stop slipping into
the tail.
And, you know, this is a great robust way
to approach YouTube.
It didn't satisfy us however because we're
not entirely sure how an approach like this,
you know, that runs bots on the side and that,
you know, works principally with YouTube's
nano data can account for videos like this.
>> I'm into nuggets, ya'll.
I'm into nuggets, ya'll.
McNuggets, McNuggets, McNuggets, McNuggets,
McNuggets, McNuggets.
Ketchup with mayo.
What?
McNuggets, McNuggets, McNuggets, McNuggets,
McNuggets, McNuggets.
Chicken McNuggets.
>> GREEN: Now, this is my favorite video on
YouTube of all time.
And it's my favorite video because this is
a video that I think we can see as a kind
of coalescence of many of these issues.
But this video that we've just watched there
is ultimately an ad, a commercial for McDonalds.
It runs for 30 seconds.
It's great on television.
It opens but with this proclamation that what
we're watching is actual user-generated content.
And, to a certain extent, we are, right?
The rap was uploaded to YouTube independent,
you know, of the McDonalds campaign.
It was spotted by a transporter at New York
who negotiated a relationship between these
two fellows and McDonalds.
McDonalds then, you know, took it, cut in
the title cards about how many McNuggets you
could get for a dollar, and then, you know,
put it on television.
So, at what point, does this stop being user-generated
content, become commercial content?
At what point does this exist as commercial
content and not user-generated content?
Because it has a foot in both camps and, actually,
McDonalds, the success of this or the value
of this for McDonalds is that it is actual
user-generated content.
Now, this copy is one of many that is floating
around YouTube that were not uploaded by either
of these two guys or McDonalds, but somebody
took it off their DVR and put it up on the
site; so it is circulated then by somebody
who doesn't have an interest, near as I can
tell, in either of these two camps.
But things--this is an interesting bit of
content.
How do we come about and appraise this video?
For me, it's visuals.
It appears to be both user-generated content
and commercial material.
It is uploaded by someone who appears to be
what we might think of as an ordinary user
of YouTube, so not a sock puppet for a large
media company Web site.
So they're uploading it and sharing it because
they think it's something interesting.
It then circulates through channels on YouTube
that may not be about, you know, the promotion
of commercial media, but might be about sharing
interesting things with your friends.
These were some of the questions that we were
trying to sort of get at.
And what we did then was take a sample of
4,320 of the most popular videos on YouTube
and put together what we're calling a sort
of a content survey.
We appropriated some of the methodologies
from the social sciences to do a content analysis.
We took a team of eight researchers.
We wrote a coding book.
We worked out how we could try and classify
these videos and then we looked at them all.
Now, the sample is far too big to get the
kind of utter agreement that the social sciences
appreciates, but, you know, ultimately, what
we're trying to do is see what happens and
what are the tensions that emerge when you
try and do a project like this.
What I think is significant about it is that
we drew the content from four of the different
categories of popularity that YouTube offers.
So YouTube itself, and this is an old screenshot.
So I apologize if it has changed.
YouTube itself offers a number of different
ways to assess how popular something is.
It can be on shear reach numbers.
So it can be about most viewed.
But it can also be about some sort of engagement
metric.
And, already, we have three or four different
types of engagement metric borne into this
sample.
But we have: whether you favored it, so whether
you decided that it allows you to make a declarative
statement about who you are, whether you've
linked to another video or posted a videos
response, whether you've left a comment or
whether you've merely viewed it.
What we did was work across these four types
of popularity to try and see, well, when you
don't just look at most viewed, what ends
up being the most popular content, how is
it used, and by whom.
And so, as I said, you know, we put together
this coding book; and this is a sample of
it.
And then we did all of this stuff and these
are some numbers.
The numbers are fine; the pie chart's "funner".
So, across our sample, we are looking, you
know, based on this sample on the coding book
that we came up with, we're looking at something
that looks roughly like a 50-50 spread, all
right?
Half of--roughly half of the content in our
sample appeared to come from user-generated
sources or appeared to be user-generated,
all right?
And I'll talk in a little bit about what those
definitions mean.
And roughly half of it in our sample appeared
to be sort of traditional media.
When we look at the uploaders--and what we
did was split out the content from the uploader;
so can we make a determination about who is
uploading what?
Can we a determination about what is the type
of content and who was putting it where?
Well, predominantly, our sample is dominated
by what we refer to as users, by, you know,
what we think of when we think of people,
ordinary people uploading content to YouTube.
Now, as we discussed in the book, actually,
making a determination about what counts as
a "user" or not is a tricky and difficult
thing; and I'll talk a little bit about it.
When we look across the different categories
of population, we get the pyramid shape, if
you arrange the bars the right way.
And so we get this pyramid shape that says,
you know, on the side of the side of most
favorited and most viewed videos, we a see
a predominance of content from traditional
media sources.
And this is in the sample that we put together.
So, you know, on the side of the most discussed
and most responded, we tend to see a predominance
of videos that appear to be user-created.
And so if we look at traditional content--I
should note that when we were doing this,
it was primary season and we were basing the
study out of Massachusetts so we were looking
here within the US, and we did it at a time--we
started it before the regionalization and
completed it after the regionalization.
So, along the way, YouTube became a little
fractured even for our sample.
You know, we see a lot of information and
opinion content when we think about traditional
media.
And this makes sense if we think about what
people are doing on YouTube.
You know, YouTube, to a great extent, follows
the mainstream news agenda when we think about
a traditional content as being uploaded there.
So, you know, it's a place where you upload
the last two minutes of the football game
because you want to be able to celebrate that
moment.
Midway through our sample, there was an earthquake
in Peru; and so, all of a sudden, all of these
videos about the earthquake in Peru popped
up.
You know, those people try and share both
material about what's happening, but also
go to YouTube as a source of information.
Now, there was a little bit, a small degree
of the sort of stuff that the large media
companies were concerned with, you know, the
uploading of content as a way to get around
official distribution channels.
But what we found, that it was often content
that came from outside of the US or in languages
other than English, and, ultimately, I suspected,
it's serving diasporic audiences, so audiences
who don't really have access to this content
within their region but there is a language
community, a viewing community that might
be transnational.
You know, and this brings us to the Susan
Boyle event, you know, which for anyone living
outside of the US or perhaps I should be honest,
for anyone living in Australia, you know,
who grew up watching a broadcast system that
featured a lot of imported content.
This idea of going somewhere online because
there's a major news event to which, you know,
you don't have access to the content is a
really ordinary way to try and keep up with
the discussions that are going on.
But the Susan Boyle thing points, I think,
to the interrelationship when you're thinking
about traditional content on YouTube between
some of the mainstream news agenda and content
flows.
So Susan Boyle becomes an event partly because
it's on YouTube; but it ends up on YouTube
partly because it's a major event; and so
the two were sort of linked together in a
cycle.
So we find traditional content used to mark
tastes--sorry--to perform tastes, to mark
occasions, to catch up on events, and to comment
on sort of what is the best bit.
And I'll talk a little briefly at the end
about the comment process.
You know, when we think about the preponderance
of music videos on YouTube and also the, in
our sample, the large amount of traditional
content that appeared in the most favorited
category, it makes a whole lot of sense.
Sticking a music video in your profile page
is a key way in which we express some sort
of identity.
Music has long been linked to the performance
and the construction of identity across social
networking.
And so, you know, that we see UMG and other
music labels appearing way up the top of the
most viewed list on YouTube makes sense.
You know, it's part of what we do.
If we look at user-created content, we see
almost the flipside.
You know, in our sample, the user-created
content was dominated by vlogging that kind
of--what I think is probably emblematic of
YouTube for the performance to camera.
But there is, of course, you know, wonderful
diversity when we look at user-created content,
from, you know, the lip-syncing girls in their
bedroom through the performances like Ty's
or those little bits of, those little oddities
like two otters holding hands, you know, where
we use YouTube to share this kind of--and
celebrate these trivial moments; but, at the
same time, we see this other kind of performance--sorry--art
video art pieces.
So, the little Mario picture is just this
YouTube thing that happens.
It's called "YouTube Poop."
And what it's comprised of are a lot of rapid
cuts of usually generally very bad, 1990s,
Saturday morning cartoons although they are
starting to branch out now into episodes of
Naruto and whatnot.
And it's put together in almost nonsensical
fashion--the idea is to juxtapose these little
bits of content.
Hopefully, if you're lucky, you can get it
to sound like they are swearing; but it is
this incredibly large YouTube phenomena.
And it doesn't make any sense outside of YouTube
because what it represents, I think, is a
demonstration of your technological prowess,
you know, the same way that game play videos
that we might see uploaded, you know, demonstrate
how well you can jump a bike in Grand Theft
Auto.
YouTube is a place where we see this kind
of playfulness with the tools of video editing
that now have been democratized.
And I think the other thing we see when we
look at vlogging particularly is an incredible
reflexivity about the way that YouTube works
and about the identity of being a YouTube
vlogger.
And so this is a little video by--actually,
a short segment of this--by an Australian
vlogger who vlogs in the name, communitychannel.
And her vlogs are a mix between--a lot of
times, often comment on what's happening on
YouTube itself and the identity of YouTube
vloggers.
>> So I would like to ask you guys: Do you
get the same thing because I find what people
ask me extremely odd?
And for some reason everywhere I go, it doesn't
matter whose, they have the same notions of
what goes on on YouTube.
>> Hey.
>> Hi.
>> So, listen, David told me that you do YouTube
videos.
>> Oh, did he?
>> That's so weird, right?
What do you talk about?
>> Just stuff.
>> Do you ever, you know...
>> What?
>> You know, do you ever, you know...
>> No.
What?
>> Come on.
You know, do you have a...
>> What?
>> You know, you just press to dial-8000 down
there.
I'll make all your wishes come true.
>> No, I don't...
>> GREEN: She goes on to--and the entire video
goes for a good number of minutes to confront
and I suppose correct some of the perceptions
about what it means to be a vlogger, about
the motivations, you know, for all of these
people to broadcast themselves.
And so I want to sort of start moving into
this sort of the wrap-up of all these and
I want to talk about what the implications,
you know, all of YouTube might be for the
media space and also what are the challenges
and that sort of things with some of the challenges
YouTube faces as it moves forward.
I really like binaries.
I think binaries are a great way to think
things through.
And when I think about YouTube, you know,
it forces us to think about the growing relationship
between, you know, professional production
and amateur production, between promotional
uses of content or platforms and social uses,
between, you know, the value of impressions
and the value of expressions, which we still
don't yet have an effective way to value,
between--the difference between being engaged
with something and how we might measure engagement
through the sorts of matrix that make the
world go round and what it means to participate
in a community in a system; but also the relationships
between distribution channels and making use
of a platform like YouTube, you know, as if
it was a distribution channel and what the
politics and potentials of platforms might
be.
YouTube has, I think, a lumpy relationship,
say, with the transition of television to
the online space.
You know, this is hulu, in case anyone of
you didn't realize; and, you know, this is
ultimately the large, big media's response
to YouTube.
I thought it's fascinating when hulu was being
put together, the discussion in the trade
press was all about putting together a YouTube
killer.
And yet what hulu does and what YouTube do,
very, very different things.
And online distribution platform tuned for,
say, a broadcast model is very, very different
to what YouTube might be.
And I want to just take a minute to just quote
Quincy Smith who I think is one of the cleverest
people in this space.
Here's a presentation from a little while
ago now where he is talking about CBS' response
to a content appearing on YouTube.
>> SMITH: CBS channel on YouTube who's putting
clips up on Letterman all day long--he interviewed
Paris Hilton a couple of weeks ago--and somebody
named MangoFace94 ripped it off and uploaded
the thing.
And right when they were like 8,000 lawyers
just primed at the pump to kill probably the
number one fan of Letterman, thankfully, the
media company got this sight of mind clear
to say: Why don't we embrace it?
If we can wrap around a safe, clean, well-lit
environment to monetize this thing, what's
the difference between at MangoFace94 and
CBS' editors?
The users have seen what they can do with
it.
So, how--are you going to tell the users they
can't do anything more?
That's ridiculous.
Media needs to be more comfortable with users
as editors.
>> GREEN: He says--there are two very interesting
things I just want to pick out for a second.
First of all, I both agree and disagree with
Quincy Smith.
I think he is one of the cleverest people
in the space.
I think this little presentation--and this
is excerpt from an Ad Age video--is quite
revealing.
You know, he says, look, if we're going to
deal with MangoFace94 who might be the number
one fan of Letterman, then maybe we should
embrace it.
If we can wrap around a safe, clean, well-lit
environment to monetize this thing, what's
the difference between MangoFace94 and CBS'
editors?
And the difference is that I'm not sure that
MangoFace94 cares about the existence of safe,
clean, well-lit, monetizable environment.
You know, and I think, fundamentally, that
represents one of the challenges that YouTube
faces going forward.
hulu was an attempt to create a safe, clean,
well-lit environment that you can wrap stuff
around and blah, blah, blah.
I agree however that media needs to be more
comfortable with uses as editors.
What that might mean however is a different
orientation to the way we derive value from
the space, to the way that we think about
the ultimate purpose and value of this kind
of online experience especially because--and
this is an article from Ad Age that is about
six months after Quincy's presentation, unofficial
streams, unofficial uploads of Letterman's
clips are still outranking the official streams
from CBS.
You know, and part of that is because perhaps
the fans know better about what the market
wants.
And part of it, you know, might be because
it's actually in CBS' favor to embrace these
guys as editors and let it go.
What I think this forces us to think about
however is how we think about uploading content
to YouTube, you know, what it means to participate.
You know, I'd like to point out, of course,
that not all uploading is always regardless
of what the content is.
But the reason I say this is because I don't
think that all uploading is necessarily publishing.
I think we need to move beyond the broadcast
model which is fundamentally oriented around
distribution.
A lot of the uploading of, say, traditional
media content or even, you know, shots of
a panda sneezing at the zoo to YouTube is
an attempt to share something.
But what it reveals to us beyond, you know,
the fact that while people like to share stuff
is what it means to be a media audience member.
So audienceship always happens behind close
doors.
You know, the great problem with the broadcast
space is that can't actually see people watching
television.
It's something that they've done and is completed
as soon as it's over.
You can measure how many people turn the television
set on, right?
But even, you know, most of the large-scale
biometrics that we have treat viewing as if
it was a singular thing.
If the set is on, then you must be watching
it.
What does "watching it" mean?
Well, you're obviously sitting there looking
at what's happening, not you doing the ironing,
not you going into the bathroom, not you getting
a cup of tea, not you sitting there with the
television on while you prepare your presentation
or have a chat with your friend.
What YouTube allows us to see, I think, is
the experience of audienceship because if
I upload two minutes of the Family Guy, I'm
perhaps not trying to publish those two minutes
of Family Guy.
Maybe what I'm doing is the participatory
culture equivalent of walking to the office
and reenacting two minutes of the Family Guy,
right?
Actually, doing some works at QUT, there's
a lot about the fact that audiences in the
current age no longer need to rely on auxiliary
media forms to speak back to the media system.
So it used to be, if you are dissatisfied
with something or if you love something, you
might write a letter to the editor of your
newspaper, right?
And then perhaps you went on to the Internet
when the Internets were invented and you might
write a screed or participate in a discussion.
We're currently in a moment where if you are
in love with something or you are dissatisfied
with something, you can actually access that
material itself.
Media has become audio-visual content, has
become tangible.
And so what we get is a situation where users
can do the very things and produce content
that not only looks like but is the very content
to which they were responding.
Well, that's where we need to reevaluate what
we think about when we think about what it
means to be an audience member, what it means
to be a publisher.
I think the other thing we need to think about
is that not all users on YouTube especially
are necessarily amateurs.
This is the Ford Models site although this
is a bit of a dated shot.
But Ford Models has a great YouTube channel.
I really, really like it.
A lot of the content is content you might
see somewhere else.
All right, so if we had the Fashion channel,
a lot of the content, this sort of stuff we
might see there.
Yeah, but YouTube-- Ford Models puts it up.
They own the rights to it.
They also sell redistribution rights and the
rights elsewhere.
We need to think of Ford Models as a user,
the same way we think of the people in the
room, you know, the casual users; and we need
to break down, I think, the idea that, you
know, on one side of the fence is large media,
and on the other side of the fence is everybody
else because in the YouTube world, on one
side of the fence is YouTube Inc.; on the
other side of the fence is everybody else.
And, yes, you know, we have a diversity.
We've got large media producers and small
media producers.
We've got good content and we've got bad content.
You know, but what we have is an incredibly
diverse user pool.
And when we look at, you know, uploads across
the popularity category in our sample, we
see both a large number of--and this is--the
little numbers are the numbers of videos uploaded
so both a large number of large media producers
who are actively using the site; but we also
come across the sites like No Good TV.
Now, No Good TV produces lavish style content.
You know, it's the sort of stuff you might
se on Spike.
They show up to interview Will Ferrell and
they get their two and half minutes like everybody
else; but it's online distribution only, all
right?
They are what otherwise we would have thought
of as an independent media company--you know,
independent producer.
Something like YouTube forces us to reevaluate
whether they represent the kind of traditional
fold or whether they are more like, you know,
the sort of casual users.
And this is especially true when we think
about the kind of entrepreneurial vloggers
out there so people like Marina Orlova who
does--and I can't pronounce it.
So she has the definition or origin of words.
And it's--no, philology.
I used to say it--okay.
So that's what she does, and she is incredibly
successful.
But her mode is inherently consistent with
the way that vlogging works on YouTube.
So she responds to her audiences.
She responds to comments.
She gives shout-outs across the vlogging community.
She shows up in other people's videos and
she delivers her content.
She produces and she engages in a mode of
production that might be akin to the sorts
of stuff that we see with Oprah.
You know, both of them produce a program that's
oriented around conversation.
And yet Oprah's YouTube channel is principally
designed not to respond to the YouTube community
but to drive content--to drive viewers back
to television.
And so I think not only do we need to think
about not all users being amateurs, I think
we need to think about not all vlogging or
uploading--so not all vlogging are user-created
production being something that's, A, monetized
through commercials or ads or, B, something
that's just people telling us what they think
about stuff.
Much of it is a business.
And if we look at the most subscribed users
over time, we see a distinction between the
most viewed.
So this was just from last night.
If we look at, you know, at most viewed, we
see large media companies.
If we look at most subscribed, we sure it
might be, say, lured audiences, we see a larger
number of this kind of entrepreneurial vloggers.
And so now we've come to the sort of the concluding
point.
And let's take a minute to talk about the
sort of uncertain futures that YouTube faces
as it moves forward.
Speaking at Mipcom last year, Chad Hurley
talked about YouTube being a site for empowerment.
You know, it empowers consumers of online
video, it empowers advertisers, and it empowers
content owners.
I think this discourse of empowerment is active
and a fine, you know, description of the space.
I think this discourse of empowerment and
the users that it's trying--those three stakeholders
that it's trying to serve stretches YouTube
in ways that it's not entirely sure how to
respond to and puts it in a really tough position.
So looking at it, you know, the overall impression
is that of a company negotiating a range,
especially once it's nationalized, is a range
of competing national regulatory structures
and corporate demands while at the same time
maintaining a brand image that's based ultimately
on sort of universal accessibility.
And so tensions arise on YouTube around the
need to control which market certain content
can be accessed by or navigate content regulations,
censorship ratings in particular states.
Increasingly, it appears that these tensions
are resolved through the selective use of
content, specific geographical filters but
with no real responsibility to disclose the
details or reasoning behind many of these
decisions to users, and users, generally none
the wiser, when content suddenly isn't available
in their region or when they can't get YouTube
altogether.
YouTube has challenges that try to manage,
you know, the interests and provide for these
large media producers while at the same time
responding to the user base that ultimately
it's where livelihood rests on.
And this is a user base that knows a lot about
YouTube but also sometimes seems kept out
in the dark from decisions that are made or
the motivations that are made.
And this user base includes, I think, large
media producers and, you know, the young people
at home.
So, moving forward, YouTube needs to work
out how to negotiate these tensions or they
will tear it apart especially, you know, when
we get estimations as we had recently about
how much money YouTube is going to lose in
the next four quarters.
I think, at the end of the day, we need to
realize however that YouTube serves a fundamental
and important cultural service.
As much as it is a site that offers great
opportunity for monetization and commercial
value, it is also a site where much of the
new culture activity is being played out.
I think YouTube has a responsibility to try
and weigh out how it keeps itself alive and
the services it provides, you know, to commercial
media users with its responsibility and I
suppose some sort of public service obligation
that it respect the fact that it is a site
where people are rewriting popular culture.
And I'm more than happy now to take questions
because that's all that I've prepared.
So I'm sorry it ends with a bit of a thump
but such is the way.
Thank you.
If people have questions, we ask that you
use the mike.
>> BRANDON: Thanks so much.
My name is Brandon.
I sell advertising on YouTube.
>> GREEN: Excellent.
>> BRANDON: And one thing that I often tell
people about how to be successful on YouTube
as a, you know, as a channel, as an individual
is to have been here about three years ago
or at least to have been on YouTube about
three years ago.
I mean, if you look at that list of most subscribed
channels, that's--they all have been around
for awhile.
>> GREEN: Yeah.
>> BRANDON: What would you say, what are other
things that they have in common?
So if somebody is starting up now...
>> GREEN: Yeah.
>> BRANDON: What, you know, whether they are
a brand or an individual, could propel them
to the top?
>> GREEN: Yeah.
So I think YouTube is a great collection of
fragments.
You know, and so I think, you know, the first
thing about success is having a clear sense
of what success might mean on the site.
I think sometimes people come to it and look
for incredible reach.
And what YouTube could be very good for is
providing targeted reach and very, very good
targeted reach.
In order for you to do that--but I think you
need to understand who are the other big players
in your little niche.
And so, you know, I've always said, the answer's
probably to look to the key vloggers.
You know, they are the people who innovate
the space; but they're also the people who
understand, I think, the way the space operates.
And when you look at what they do, often,
the most successful ones are participants
in the space.
So they're not just uploading content.
You know, they're getting involved in debates
that are going on.
They're responsive to other videos.
So, it's not just about them broadcasting
themselves; but active broadcasting is actually
one that requires some kind of response to
your audience.
And so it's not inherent--it's not altogether
conversational but it's certainly not that
broadcast yourself and let's sort of--let's
just push it out.
So, yes, I agree, you know, get here three
years ago, you know, and grow up in the place
or learn from the people who have growing
up in the space.
How do they respond to their communities?
What's the language they use?
What do they offer up?
And there was a video awhile ago that some
people uploaded that's a glitch from an EA
sports game where Tiger Woods appears to walk
on water.
And, you know, some people uploaded it and
it become incredibly popular and was, at one
point, ranked as the fourteenth most viewed
video within the video game community on YouTube.
So the company that manages EA sees this.
They happen to have Tiger Wood lying around
in a closet, something.
They take him out, you know, and they shot
a spot with him apparently walking on water.
What they then do is grab the original video
and edit the two together, drop an overlay
that says, "Look, you know, you thought it
was just in the video game, well, actually,
it is not a glitch.
Check it out.
You know, here's Tiger Woods walking on water."
You upload it, you know, you upload it to
YouTube as they did and, you know, it goes
up the charts, for that, you know, video game
community.
Well, what that does was both acknowledge
that the community is significant producing
content, you know, and it's not just sitting
there, listening to what is being pushed out,
it acknowledges the important people.
So, you know, they took the video and actually
said, "This video is significant because you
all liked it so we're going to do what you
do.
You know, we're going to use the resources
at our disposal and let the sorts of things
that you're doing.
So I think it's a good example of, you know,
a corporate effort that, you know, that responds
to the sort of the culture logics of the way
the place operates.
Hi.
>> Hi.
So YouTube is such an evolving platform.
And I'm sure in the months that you've been
writing the book, you've seen a lot of the
changes, you know, of long-form content and
new advertising form as of promoted videos
and pre-roll and new homepage units.
So what kind of challenges did that present
you as you were writing the book?
And also, what do you think the next book
on YouTube might be about?
>> GREEN: Right.
So, the challenges that posed to us--well,
the academic, probably the book publishing
cycle moves a lot slower than YouTube does.
And, you know, I was kicking myself after
we had sent the book to the publisher when
agreements that we had referred to in the
book fell apart between YouTube and certain
corporate partners, you know.
And so some of the challenges that we found
in writing the book is that YouTube has a
tendency to just change so, you know, you'd
wake up one morning as I did--I think it was
the 6th of July last year--and all of a sudden
there's all of these regions on YouTube--maybe
in the year before.
And, you know, when I went to bed, there was
one YouTube and when I woke up in the morning,
you know, there were a whole bunch and they
just kept getting more, you know.
And, you know, from--all of a sudden, we had
to confront the fact that YouTube is generally
the politics of being transnational.
We hadn't anticipated that it was going to
happen, you know, and we think we read most
of the things that YouTube says it's going
to do.
We knew it was in the works.
You know, it's the same with a lot of the
community management policies, you know, that
I think sometimes catch people by surprise
because people aren't necessarily when the
changes are going to happen.
And so, for us, that was the greatest challenge,
you know, that and the fact that many of the
things that you say become irrelevant when--or
fundamentally affected by, you know, YouTube
opening up in the US and attempts to leave
a long-form content, you know, or agreements
are finally reached.
The next book about YouTube, I think, will
address needs to engage with the relationship
between YouTube and the rest of the world.
This is a book written by two Australians;
one of them happens to live the US.
But, you know, this is a book that doesn't
quite get to partly because of the time we
were writing, the challenges that YouTube
has as it becomes some sort of a global entity.
So, you know, local broadcasters are regulated
quite heavily in many regions of the world
by content laws, by advertising laws, by regulation
restrictions, regulations and restrictions.
YouTube has to confront that as it works in
different markets.
It's a source of frustration to many people
who don't understand why and who perhaps see
YouTube as letting them down because this
content isn't available in your region and
the question is why.
You know, because in Germany, it might not
be available for a range of reasons that have
to do with the way the nation regulate its
media representations.
You know, in other regions, it may be because
there isn't a licensing agreement.
And I think that is a particular source of
conflict that is still being worked out and
looms large as YouTube moves forward.
>> And can we have a copy of your presentation?
>> GREEN: Yes.
I'll talk to you about that later.
Oh, and the book over here, if anyone would
like them, and I suppose I'll sign it if you
like.
Yeah, on the table over here, and there are
some in the library as well.
Hi.
>> Hi.
So one thing that we often talk with our partners,
our advertisers about is understanding how
to evaluate the collective of these comments
or favorites or whatnot.
So I know that you took a look across like
the top 4,000 that were like rising to the
top, but did you ever look at any way about,
like, at one specific video and/or multiple
specific videos and then attempt to, like,
place--like, ideally, what I'd like to be
able to do is place different metrics or values
to those different things and then have a
way to monitor them instead of only being
able to look at the most viewed list.
So did you all apply any sort of like code
or algorithm to specific, you know, actions
that happen against the video?
>> GREEN: No, because we looked at videos--individual
videos in-depth.
We didn't develop any kind of code or algorithm
to apply across the board.
We looked at some individual videos in-depth
and sort of looked at their response and those
sorts of things.
I'd be happy after this or at some other point
to talk to you about that because I have some
ideas; they're just not altogether probably
formed right enough to be sent out across
the whole world.
But I'd be happy to sit down because I do
think it's possible to do.
And I think there are number of kind of canny
ways that you can go about doing it.
All right.
Well, it's like, you know, five to twelve--five
to one now.
So I'll be at lunch.
Thanks all for coming.
And there are books and I will sign them.